I select movie chimpanzee yeah that was
like some fizzy things like holy cow
what movie was that look Rico chimpanzee
who documentary yeah I couldn't realize
chimps did calculated cruelty mm-hmm
yeah right well we know better because
we've advanced but if we hadn't we'd be
like man I don't want to [ __ ] live in
a house
I like the chimp ways bro chimp ways to
go this is it man chimp life life right
now but we in a way to the AI might be
like those chimps I don't make how much
do we think about chimps not much very
little these chimps are at war I saw
that David Attenborough documentary on
chimps where they were eating those
colobus monkeys and ripping them apart
it's just oh this is why people are so
crazy we came from that thing
yeah exactly no Oren is the final
boarding yeah I gotta like better
philosophy yeah they're like swingers he
just seemed resolved everything with sex
yeah the only rules they have is the mom
won't bang the son that's it okay
they're good women yeah good women the
bonobo community everybody else is
banging it out yeah I haven't seen the
bonobo movie well they're disturbing
just at a zoo you know you have bonobos
at the zoo just constantly going nicely
[ __ ] yeah and they don't care gay
straight whatever this is foggy I
haven't seen one of us at a zero it's
probably like not not on the PG section
yeah I don't think they have them at
many zoos we've looked at pretty awkward
I think that's the thing they like to
keep regular chimps at zoos cuz bonobos
are just always jacking off yeah what's
that they up in San Diego really
interesting item yeah I mean how many
other in a cage you know thing Brian
it's gonna be pretty intense
[Music]